got a news flash for you bozos the card
game is back on sale oh my God the
original edition of the card game some
of our favorite questions right here got
about 50 or so of them sold a bunch of
them put them on the shelf for a little
while now we're doing one final run of
the original series one last job baby
it's a good good time to get hammered
with your friends and find out at the
people that you know and that you love
are garbage so do yourself a favor the
link is in the description pick up a
pack today because they're gonna go
quick oh yeah and that ain't it tubby we
got Road dates baby we got two shows in
Atlanta coming up in November then we're
going to Charlotte North Carolina if
you're in the area get those tickets for
that we got two in Philly that are sold
out we got one left in Providence Rhode
Island those tickies are moving we got
one left in Boston that is for sure
gonna sell out get those tickets we won
a party see you there gang this episode
is brought to you by established titles
call yourself a lord or a lady by going
over there and buying one square foot
dedicated Scottish woodlands and it's a
great way to preserve them yeah guys
with every order established titles
plants a tree and works with global
Charities to support Global restoration
efforts so not only are you becoming
royalty yeah you're also giving back the
mother earth baby go uh title packs give
you at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland and an official
certificate with a Crest so it all
checks out your certificate has a plot
number on it so you can see the location
of your land don't be one of those bozos
getting out a star or a moon or whatever
what about something you can use we're
talking real estate let's go buy low
sell high you can officially change your
name to Lord or lady uh you can use the
name on your credit card plane tickets
whatever you want or just use it to land
uh hot a hot date or something you know
what I mean score with chicks uh the
first 200 people purchasing the title
pack using our link will effectively be
next to our plots oh nice with a few
minutes of walking we can build our own
garbage Kingdom baby to the Moon that's
pretty sweet it makes an amazing last
minute gift to Savage is actually
running an early Black Friday sale plus
if you use the code garbage to get an
additional 10 off go to
establishtails.com to get your gifts now
and help support the show do it welcome
to another exciting Edition
[Music]
garbage
[Music]
favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage hey little shall we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they're going to be
classy yeah nothing just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host stage Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antuti's basement just saw
her coming out of the shower okay cool
yikes like The Conjuring okay my co-host
is coming at you from across the table
that one's got to go back in the oven
for a little bit what are you talking
about
God damn it uh I was gonna have another
one but I went with that thought a
little physical humor I haven't heard it
but you should have went with the other
one plus it is Halloween
maybe the kids liked it anyway my
judgmental co-host is sitting across the
table
you didn't laugh it's your fault he's
the CEO of are you garbage he's an
international businessman he's also my
best pal of the whole wide world and I
love him give it up for KJ
Kevin James Ryan Hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate if you subscribe over there on
iTunes we got full video available over
there on YouTube and those numbers are
it's cooking over there 100K okay listen
I know the amount of people that listen
audio-wise I get those reports about
once a quarter so listen hop over there
on the used tubes even if you listen to
the audio right now pull out your phone
get us over a hundred thousand with that
goddamn pack of all my P Diddy black and
I get the the the hesitation I don't
like signing up for stuff I don't like
subscribing then they got your email
they got your info in they're knocking
on your daughter asking you for money
the foleys don't like that stuff but
those YouTube people are good people you
subscribe you get the you get the
episode when it comes out you know
what's going on you don't want to go
looking for It's a Good Time come on I
want that silver yeah uh and then
obviously uh the greatest goddamn
website of all time oh yeah
www.patreon.com yeah that's the one
check it the [ __ ] out baby we are
cooking with gas over there I just
looked today there's over 90 episodes of
ay bonus ayg there's over 90 episodes of
horror feelings which by the way is the
fan favorite The Runaway The Runaway
star of the pack you got the video we
got videos we got us down the shore we
got us golfing we got the golf
tournament we got both The Cribs of my
childhood home The Cribs of your
childhood home uh the camping tripping
got the whole [ __ ] nine y'all go
check it out we hit the goal we're doing
Storage Wars we still got to get down to
Disney we're gonna have that coming up
don't miss out gang it's a good time and
speaking of Good Times how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones and twos he
crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for Tebow McMuffin Toby
McMullen everybody what's up dudes
what's up brother what up T-Bone boys
talk to me down Air at skank Fest yeah I
got a tip from one friend of the show Mr
Sean Patton good good [ __ ] that guy love
that guy the best on the Halloween tip
when he was growing up when he was
trick-or-treating they would eat the
candy between each house
so so the bag looked light when they
showed up there was no bag whoa oh my
God they would come home empty-handed
holy [ __ ]
that's insane isn't that crazy dude
that's wild how sick would you be
I couldn't do that this is so this is my
question okay I could never wrap my head
around that no because I'd want to have
the uh I'd be like um not the hobbits
who the people that lived in the
mountains
the dwarves yeah I'd be like I want to
hoard it don't have it all there I put
everything out I put the kitkats with
the kitkats I put the Reese's cup with
the Reese's cup then we start
negotiating I think I remember I did
that once right I had all my candy and I
I left it in a paper bat like you know I
took it out of the pillowcase and I put
it on like a big like shopping bag you
know what I mean uh what's my score
man am I beagle Rusty ate all of it they
say dogs aren't supposed to eat
chocolate this guy ate about ten
thousand Crunch bars 47 grits thousand
Snickers oh man yeah English [ __ ] now
rappers for a month we had a Visa having
to tour through like three fam of each
land the [ __ ] is that one of the
Australian hound dogs you've seen them
they're like golden color good looking
dogs they kind of look like hanzi but
with a pink nose a pink like a like a
like a lighter nose anywho he went
through like my dog's American by the
way I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
you're [ __ ] your dog from Down Under
can kick rocks
this is goddamn America my dog's got a
black nose all right if I get eaten
Vegemite surfing all day
it tastes his tail in the wrong
direction this [ __ ] guy he went
through like three families worth of
Easter baskets and nothing happened to
him yeah I thought if a dog touched a
piece of chocolate he would die that's
the will to live I guess okay so so this
is my question to you too if you had to
eat the candy from each house how many
houses do you think you could make at
six I would give up not a big candy guy
a nibble
man that's uh half the Eastern Seaboard
you'd make it to North Carolina
hey Tom Hanks
um I would just be real sick
I would be real soon anyway I would be
real sick at the end of the night
because that really slows you down damn
man that's wild it's a genius move by
the parents really tightens up the whole
operation yeah you run for 20 30 minutes
all right oh wait his parents made him
do that you don't get a bag you can eat
the candy oh geez that's like a game
show
that is like a Chinese game show that's
like a social services game show right
there holy cow
take what you can carry that's wild man
Sean Patton is a badass though love that
Sean Pat tell you that right now I can
see that
um yeah I would want to have it all
go home you dump it out you throw
something on maybe an Elvira or a
monsters or something like that you
throw it you dump everything out you
organize everything start trading too
you start that's when it starts
negotiating yeah I don't like whatever
that's when Patty starts wetting her
beaks on the mini Snickers that's what
she used that that was her Vig she'd
come in and take her taste there's
always the mini Snickers you like
operating for free around here don't you
many Snickers and Reese's Peanut Butter
Cups were always hot Commodities at the
folio yeah she does have a refined
palette so she does the Snickers was the
what was the mom's candy bar kids didn't
really mess you do mess with Snickers
just started yeah you didn't I didn't
really mess with Snickers I remember my
brother did it that was like broccoli
without even European it's like what the
[ __ ] how mature are you dude yeah that
yeah no kidding crunch for sure Reese
anything with peanut butter but once you
start getting into weird nougaty Bean
all peanuts or something yeah it's like
trail mix no thank you but now I love
them Checkers is the best candy bar ever
great I would somehow come back to that
every three episodes speaking of food
that's okay believe it or not I have a
guy I have a question for you
um if this is trash or not so we were
away uh we had uh someone watching the
spot watching the kitty cat we had a cat
sitter okay when were you away we were
just away last weekend oh it's right
okay yeah sorry sorry I didn't realize
she was away she was away yeah okay we
were both away so
um
we had the cat sitter
same person that we've used you know for
for maybe like a year or whatever anywho
um we didn't get a chance to get to the
grocery store so she bought a couple of
things oh boy she bought some waffles
and she bought some uh you know those
preggers
um Dr prager's uh veggie patties no but
some of them Frozen veggie Frozen veggie
patties is it trash yes if you eat the
food yes yes 100 she also lived body
wash that I've been using it smells
fantastic and a dildo hahaha
it's all very Lube you're using on
yourself
put a little on your toes
is that trash oh yeah dude for sure for
sure for sure I used to have to Airbnb
my spot out as you know I've mentioned
that a handful of times and people would
be like at checkout and be like hey you
know when you check out just leave the
key and they would like message you like
nice like hey thanks for checking out
but that's a big thing of staying in an
Airbnb in New York it's like you're
gonna make a couple bills at home people
are traveling it's so expensive there's
a half of lasagna yeah so like there's
you know a half a baked ziti in there if
you need I'd be like what are you
[ __ ] you think we're gonna eat some
food that's some stranger made in my
apartment I'm already torching the bed
so it's she's not a stranger
so I'm assuming you ate it with this
delight of Defense oh yeah what do you
mean what'd you eat I ate the uh choose
the healthier option here because you're
paying yourself in no Corner no I ate
the veggie patty yeah in between two
waffles
I was out of bread Toby has an appetizer
for my breakfast
no I had a waffle too of course you did
come on man I was like an Eggos in there
you find Eggos in the freezer you make a
move she also you're not surrounded by
enablers she must uh she she must be she
she's she's good with fruit she got the
the good maple syrup from Trader Joe's
who's buying a [ __ ] bottle of maple
syrup for staying for a weekend because
she wanted to take care of herself
maple syrup is expensive okay
okay good stuff uh this next weigh-in
will be in torresante
all right let's get down to it this is a
family episode game yeah as you know
when you sign up for the patreon you can
get your question read on a year and
we're gonna do that right here with the
KIPP Arena kicking it off let's go baby
oh baby we got some Gators with the
heaters of questions this time and uh I
want to start off with this one because
we were just uh you know we've been
traveling around a lot this one's from
and I never thought about this this is
from Spencer 20 Bowser here shout out to
the [ __ ] top race out there look at
that is it garbage if the majority of
your vacations you go to are at the
casino hotels because they give you the
best deals
do they yeah because they want you I
think this question's asked under the
assumption you're not gambling you're
just going to stay at the hotel sure
which I feel would be the trashiest so
casino hotels they give the lowest rates
because I guess under the assumption is
you're there they're hating over to head
for the breakfast you're [ __ ] you're
losing money at the tables sure you want
to keep they want you it's easier to get
you at the tables once you're in the
door is this Vegas we're talking about I
don't know he doesn't he doesn't say
where else is gambling legal like that
where else can this casino is almost I
would argue in every country or in every
state there's casinos sure there's
casinos at in Philadelphia There's
casinos in Jersey if you're in New York
if it's not like a warm destination or
like near a beach or something yeah
that's a tough look yeah yeah I mean if
you're going like you know if you're
staying at the [ __ ] Casino outside
Disney world that is a yeah I'll even
give you that but if you're not if
you're if you're the happiest place on
Earth you're at an Indian casino if you
live in Michigan and it's summertime and
you take your family away and you go go
to a casino in Philly and just stay
there and do the pool and all that stuff
that's that's trashy that's that's trash
yeah if it's near the beach I'll give
you something I'll give you a little
leeway on that ashore I understand that
too but yeah but also I mean
I don't know staying to walk through a
casino with like you know pool noodles
and stuff to get to the beach is a tough
look they don't make you gotta zigzag
through those goddamn things
oh man you got a blown up raft for like
you got your Boogie Board in your head
it's like I'm walking past the craps
table it's like a maze trying to get out
of there is going off the kids are
having seizures too [ __ ] much man
yeah man that's no bueno yeah that's no
good
um this one's vacation as well this is
from drew p wiener shout out to him
uh
homie of the ten bones variety says
there you go never had a question read
before are you garbage if your parents
took you and your two sisters to a
nudist colony as kids
that has to be illegal though it gets
real weird with those nudist colonies
they're not as fun not everybody's hard
and [ __ ] like that is that what you
expect yeah what do you mean the guy
wasn't even [ __ ] what am I looking at a
soft ween over here chop it up Gary I'd
rather see a hard one than a soft one
soft ones are weird okay they're looking
at you yeah
um that's first of all they're never
saying it's never I mean this is like
old Trope you hack stuff but it's never
the people you want to be at the nudist
it's not sexual either it's never like
sexy god like people playing volleyball
you're halfway there what are you doing
she's got clothes off make a move no or
something as a kid though
I mean I would have been walking around
with a little Stinger the whole time
I don't know check it out Boop yeah what
again they're not as I need a good I
need a good uh as a child as a little
kid when you're a 12 year old kid if you
see boobs it doesn't matter why could
that could be on a dog it doesn't matter
now I don't like the nipples on a dog
I'm very staunch on no nips on any dog I
saw one that was pierced the other day
um
all I know is that I still wouldn't do
it for I I think even at 12 or 13 I'd be
more like
gross that it's just more like
mechanical or something there's good
naked and bad naked those kids
definitely grew up to sell nitrous in a
parking lot at some point yeah those
guys they followed around fish or
something yeah I wonder what the parents
do
I don't know the nudist colony on
vacation probably a couple of shows yeah
it just said it would take us to Noodles
colonies for the weekend
I don't know I've seen a couple of those
on HBO
unlike uh yeah something like that man
they're like out in the woods and [ __ ]
yeah I think it can't be in Midtown what
are you talking about standing in the
line of the Chipotle family walk through
the casino like that man uh yeah no
that's uh that's that's gotta be illegal
I think right that can't be yeah it
sounds like hold on you think the kids
were naked too either way I don't think
I don't think you can put your children
in an invite that's like
you can't put your children in an
environment where they're a bunch of
naked adult kids are naked that's real
[ __ ] up yeah I don't think some old
creepy dude look at it Mr weiner right
in please yeah God damn it uh that's
I mean there was there was a while in
New York there's one not too far from
here where Comics were doing shows it's
in like new you know upstate-ish
somewhere probably two hours away and
Comics were doing shows all the time did
you have to be naked as a comic no no no
no no the comics were clothed but I
remember like people like I'm going to
do the it was like a gig you would get
every like couple of months or somebody
you know I'm doing the naked gig I'm
doing the naked gig hmm I remember being
I was just like what the f that's
[ __ ] insane to me no thank you the
kids are naked that's [ __ ] I keep my
clothes on during hanky-panky yeah
nobody wants to see me people are eating
I'll be [ __ ] puking everywhere
um yeah I did see that naked roast
at the festival which is a site to be
seen it's uh whoo wild
who is I I didn't know what was
happening I'm like what's going on in
this room they're like the naked roast I
was like up here in there and then after
like eight seconds I was like what am I
doing this I regret this
there's a famous porn star there though
Evan Stone a dude yeah nice yeah lady I
don't know yeah Evan Stone remember Evan
Stone he was big in like the early tooth
that e Stone I remember Evan Peters
wasn't there an Evan Peters that's an
actor now
a Spider-Man I remember the guy that
used to hook up with uh Nina Hartley all
the time that's going way back down he
had like a like brown hair that was kind
of slicked back he was like muscular he
was in uh he was in Boogie Nights he was
the one banging Nina Hartley when
William H Macy walked in he's like you
mind closing the door buddy I remember
him that's what I thought you were
talking about I heard that Jason Ellis
has got a hammer on him yeah he does
there you go it's pretty good stuck
around for some of the other guys not so
great
a lot of uncuts running around too I
thought I thought I was I thought it was
in Denmark
is this Vegas or Europe What's Happening
Here somebody get the cigar Cutters that
who wears a turtleneck in Nevada I know
Jesus Christ
hey buddy crack a window on that thing
laughs
when those broke on that what's going on
um all right this one's from Ariana is
it garbage to have more than one empty
pack of smokes in your car
yeah but usually that's where they gotta
go in the back sound smoke in the car
anymore
no smoking in the Jeep okay since I got
the new one you have you yet at all not
one no not one little puff puff can you
believe that window I don't know I
genuinely don't believe that that's why
I'm that's why I'm following up until
you break and tell me the truth 100 I
haven't which I just just when you said
it I thought about it damn I could do
that that long and not break on that
haven't smoked don't let Patty smoke in
there don't let anybody smoke in here if
I want a heater I pull over and I've
noticed this from driving with you so
much I've started to adapt the to pull
it over I break it up a lot more than I
did I used to White Knuckle it all the
way through didn't matter how long it
was somebody's got to pee I'd be
bitching now hour and a half in pull
over stretch the legs have a heater get
back in the car and keep going
I think if you were still smoking in the
car you wouldn't pull over though 100
yeah yeah yeah yeah you would [ __ ]
steamroll those
stuff break
but yeah the latitude had [ __ ]
it was like a steak out there yeah that
was bad taxi heaters back
um I keep all I still in my car have
easily 12 empty packs of [ __ ] more
more beezies in there still empty just
take it in the glove box in the center
console really that's where they go that
and parking tickets you should see them
you don't clean that car that much do
you you don't you don't put a lot of
love into it no I do you do yeah yeah I
don't use it that much so that's the
thing huh so it's like the only like
actual dirt or not dirt whatever the
only actual like is like if we drive
somewhere and like we have like you know
it's like a coffee cup a bottle of water
and like something that like and a you
know if you guys are going on a long
trip like when you when you when you two
went to the wedding before you went
before you drove up to Upstate New York
did you go and get the car wash and the
car cleaned out and all that stuff no
really oh I always get the car hooked up
before I like strip always clean it out
get it fresh in yours every day this is
the difference you're putting a lot of
wear and stuff in your car mine's mine
you just said you had packs of heaters
and tickets everywhere in the glove in
the center console I said okay yeah
that's I never open because there's
nothing I'm it's like I literally get in
the car I put in drive we drive I put it
in a park and then I leave it for
weeks at a time I don't know where the
[ __ ] it is
I've started to take pictures because I
forget where it is
[ __ ] well it's like it's you know I just
take the parking ticket I gotta check to
see how many [ __ ] dings I got on that
too gotta get on that that's a bad day I
saw them putting [ __ ] boots on the
car in the neighborhood yesterday it's a
real bad day man check that out you got
the all you gotta do is put your license
and they tell you everything you got you
pay it right there I'm aware bud I'm
aware but you know you live and you
learn I like to walk on the wild side
come get me [ __ ] that's another thing
too of the new the new car
not one ticket yet clean as a whistle
well you have a parking spot true so
that'll do it
before you parked illegally for six
years
I've still rolled the dice a couple of
times yeah you get a murder out there
Kevin how about that true classic baby
true classic oh I got one on right now
under my sweatshirt it feels good it
feels loose in the right spots it feels
cozy in the right spots I get regular
t-shirts I gotta go in there I gotta do
the fat guy stretching it out true
Classics to slide rights on man they got
the nice crew neck the sleeves feel good
covers the belly it feels fantastic gang
big guys I'm telling you right now do
yourself a favor pick up a couple of
them true Classics yeah guys uh true
Classics is the One Stop Shop for casual
crewnecks polos and activewear I've this
is all I've been wearing I wear a lot of
black tees I got about 30 or 40 of them
at the crib I've always been a true
Classics man I saw it on Instagram
originally I clicked it it's fancy you
feel like a you feel like an old College
athlete you know what I mean you look a
little small T-Bone even said one time
he goes That's the best cutting t-shirt
I've ever seen on that man in his life I
look good no big deal other gears Top
Notch quality with great prices try
their polos Network Out shirt all all
you fat [ __ ] out there this is their
copy not mine they have long body
options sized excuse me 3XL for the big
man there we go don't drop the ball
upgrade your wardrobe with true Classics
get 25 I can't believe they call
everybody get 25 off drewclassics.com I
know my kind of guys uh with uh code
garbage free shipping included on
purchase over 100 that's 25 off at
trueclassics.com with code garbage
strengthen your core wardrobe with true
Classics today okay let's talk about
that beard Club oh love that beard Club
you gotta keep the beard looking Lush
you got to keep it looking thick you got
to keep it looking soft sometimes it
gets real scraggly it gets like wire you
look like a bozo if you get on a beer
Club keep it nice keep it smooth keep it
trim keep it beautiful baby with the
beard Club yeah guys as you know I'm a
bit of a chubster myself a heavy bike
boy as I call it that might be Merc
coming off shout out the heavy bike boys
I like that uh yeah got a double chin
you gotta look you got the jowls working
it really tightens it up it makes you
look all right especially if you're
balding in the front you pull here a
little distract little smoke and mirrors
as I say uh Beer Club is here to help as
the leaders uh as the leader in beard
first men's growth and grooming the
beard Club delivers Quality Hardware and
consumables that'll give you a better
thicker fuller looking beard uh head to
beardclub.com
ayg take the beard quiz use code ayg at
checkout they'll recommend the best
beard kit for you no matter what type of
beard you have the beard Club is the
perfect has the perfect kit to fit your
needs go grow your bet a little mouthful
grow your best beard today take 20 off
your first order when you go to
beardclub.com
ayg and use code ayg that's
beardclub.com
ayg code ayg for 20 off your first order
beard Club over 2 million beard served
Do It
um all right let's see here where are we
uh speaking of cars for some kind uh is
a garbage to hold your socks outside the
car on the highway to freshen them up
I don't even know
how that happens can you do that while
driving you can take your socks off I
can't
hey dude I need the bed I need a corner
it's a whole project that's crazy how
bad are your socks and where are you
going
I'm just kind of a softball game or
something like that but then you would
assume you're going home so you got to
be doing something pretty musky
work boots golf [ __ ] softball then go
into like a nice restaurant I guess
unless you're just putting on dirty
socks in the morning that's what I think
is happening sounds like it yeah yeah I
can't do the dirty socks believe I could
do dirty underwear all day I'm doing
that right now actually doing dirty
undies yeah yeah if you let them if you
wear underwear one day we've been
traveling so much I didn't have time to
do goddamn launch 100 you wear dirty
underwear you wear underwear one day you
let that sit out for two or three days
that's fresh everything I try more than
two or three days for me personally I
need about a I need about
five days you want to give it a week
yeah I need it I need close to a week to
age yeah that age age sounds like it's
cheese well no that's what you're making
down here wow this is to read I hate to
tell you there Bertelli no this is to to
reinvigorate I would say sure but the
only problem is
the then the shelf life on the business
is good you get halfway through the day
and then you oh then you start then you
start feeling it yeah yeah okay come off
right now if you want you guys want to
take a look you know what I do in the
hotel sometimes I'll leave them over the
air conditioner so your whole room
smells like ass there you go that's good
that's what you want let them get
freshened up a little bit yeah and also
too you know what those uh the air
conditioners that are that are
underneath the window in the in a hotel
that that blow up what are they called
not the window units but the the vents
right there yeah man you put your leg up
on that after you get out of the shower
whoa calm down the Middle East with that
day that's coming right off the floor is
the board that's not coming from like up
on the roof or anything that's coming
from I love that because I use the hair
big window unit I use the hair dryer
most of the time when I get out of the
shower I just like the feeling I want
everything dry and fresh down there
because I know it ain't gonna last
you know sure I hit it with that and
then I hit it with the Gold Bond spray
which I had to figure out because I
wasn't using it right I was going in
there on full automatic and I would have
it upside down and it would just this
the aerosol would come out and then by
the end it would be full but it wouldn't
work you got to pump it
shake it up pump it shake it up pump it
you are one of the great minds of our
time thank you thank you well there's a
lot of routine I was just being Freon
and spraying freon on his nuts for six
months until he found out he was doing
it wrong that can't be good for the kids
I'll tell you that yeah get out of hit
it with a layer of clear coat
so much goddamn lacquer on these things
put a little ether on it that's what I'm
pledge in the butthole
um man you are something else this guy
um
let's see here
this one's gonna get me jammed up just
even in the reading of the question
uh ten dollar Freakazoid with that uh
this is from bald 22 year old retired
linebacker oh that was the guy in
I was [ __ ] on him that's what I said
he looked like I said he looked like a
retired linebacker he was bald at 22.
uh Detroit shout out to Detroit
um Ferndale he's up there in the front
row in Detroit oh yes what is the proper
way to pronounce
I'm jammed up already this is pretty bad
I'm not wait hold on a second hold on a
second Toby get the dump button ready
Worcestershire sauce oh okay
what'd you think I was I thought it was
going to be some word that would have
would have sounded something racist
walking you right into a dark alley now
Worcestershire is that the pro what's
the Worcestershire Worcestershire sauce
I've always known it as Worcestershire
sauce Worcestershire sauce yeah I don't
think it's shires Worcestershire sauce
I think that's too
staccato is that what it is piccato
picante staccato staccato
Worcestershire sauce Worcestershire
sauce
that I mean it's Worcestershire
I'm not listening to some [ __ ]
computer it's the first thing that comes
up if you do how to pronounce
sorry what Worcestershire sauce
Worcestershire Worcestershire I don't
know if this broad knows what she's
talking about yeah it's Google's doing
it they don't know that's always Google
doesn't look like idiots no
Worcestershire okay
yeah it's great and Bloody Mary
Worcestershire sauce
that's how the Brits say it
no thank you let me check my schedule
right now yes Worcestershire what's q
line
the queue the cue to get in
that's where we get that from
well it's cued up your Netflix queue
sure you had that queued up I think is a
little different but they say that the
line in the UK that you're in line
where's the key it's at the queue the q
k or sorry Q q-u-e I uh so when Netflix
was was handing out CDs or DVDs I missed
all that I wasn't [ __ ] with Netflix
when they had the when they were sending
the there's no way Patty was letting
things get mailed to the house like that
yeah and that thought it was true yeah
not until it was streaming did we get on
board but I remember my cousins and
everybody saying yeah I have it in my
queue on Netflix that means when it's
available they're gonna send me a copy
sure that's the same thing
yeah that's one application of the word
Toby Google how uh Garth Brooks says
Worcestershire sauce
America yeah I want an American barbecue
see how jelly roll pronounces it God
damn it let's go I'm not listening
mustard
I believe you're talking about A1 Sauce
my man
yeah I'm not listening to her
get out of here with that yeah
Worcestershire Worcestershire sauce
Worcestershire Worcestershire
I've never I want I don't like it too
I've never I'm not I could never
confidently say that you don't like it
really
great I don't know it's in a lot of
things that you like do you like
cocktail sauce no you don't no
interesting you like ketchup not huge
fan but yeah I mean I'll die dabble you
like barbecue sauce sure it's in that
okay yeah sure what else do you like
I don't like it
said I said you've got to be filled with
it because I hate you you know what it's
in what Manhattans
yeah it is but I don't know what you're
talking about that and ipas uh not an
IPA man
um yeah we are
Toby cut that
uh this is from Julie a ten dollar homie
long time Bozo finally have my garbage
question ever done Coke on Christmas
Christmas Day or Christmas Eve I would
say I Christmas Day I feel would be the
sadder
Christmas Eve there's some party to it
right Christmas Eve is we're all getting
together we're joining up families
cousins friends ever your whatever that
would however you define family that
circle's coming together and you're
grabbing some cocktails you're getting
pretty crazy and at certain ages I'm
sure a bag gets broken yeah what the
cousins haven't seen him in a long time
yeah yeah yeah you got anything still
got some upstairs if it's later on with
maybe some of the older folks have gone
to bed you can't be doing bumps with
[ __ ] grandma I know yeah
by the the meatballs are out the Swedish
meatballs are still out like that I just
imagined Christmas Day some dude bumping
lines just going oh man I gotta get that
tree up
anybody got an extension cord oh man
poor kids yeah you'd be doing if you got
kids I'm talking about like college yes
of course 20s whatever your 30s 40s yeah
come on 47.
it'll be 47 this Christmas
uh yeah that's a real tough look I feel
you know although I have in my you know
uh early 20s days we would go party on
Christmas Day
Christmas Day night with the boys with
the boys yeah cause my mom would go to
my my stepdad's family's house my
brother would go to his girl you're
talking College yeah 20. when you had
that month off to do absolutely nothing
man come on that was all right pick up
everybody's got fresh gear on at the pub
you're hanging out maybe a little bit of
cash on you yeah I got a my Aunt Kate
this is for sure what happened I go to
my aunt Kate's uh in the city we'd hit
Aunt Cates it would just be me so then I
would [ __ ] you know
I would get there and God I'm gonna get
mobile out of here because I gotta get
back to the [ __ ] Hood uh you know to
meet up with the boys I'd hop out of
there and call [ __ ] Pat up and when
there's no guilt of like oh it's
Christmas I guess but when they're going
all right they're going somewhere I'm
out well it's like my whole family had
dispersed so I would go to my aunt's
house because my you know and I didn't
want to whatever so I would go there see
my aunts my uncles my grandparents so I
did all my my responsibilities were all
checked and then they start wrapping it
up because it's all older heads I go
I'll see you later you were just making
sure you hit up every house to get an
envelope yeah get greased up a bit shout
out to Aunt Carol shout out to [ __ ]
and Patty shout out to Aunt Kate they
take care of the kid shout out to Uncle
Joe NADA used to come in heavy bike with
the envelopes and Kate Hunter every time
I see her she's got no kids break you
off real quick HootSuite was great
um so I hit pad up yo
let's go spend that Christmas cash you
know what I mean everybody's flushed so
we'd go to [ __ ] in the pub man you're
just like sitting there and like no
Ambercrombie on can't tell me nothing
yeah who shoot the cops Chrissy it was
more of like Express at that time we
were feeling ourselves a little bit the
thin sweaters with like the ice cream
with like a shirt on with a button up
under it or something a nice pair of
khakis
new pair of jeans with a sticker on the
side
still says 38-32 on it or whatever again
I was always bad to show up to Christmas
dinner like your husband you got a tag
on your [ __ ]
where are the 38 29's like a Porker
I think particular has that you're
you're an upside that you're an improper
fraction or whatever it is
38 30s
that's where I was I was looking for 36
30s over in Europe and like they can't
comprehend that a guy would be that
proportion you know what I mean
that's a lean group over there
um yeah you can't but we would party and
it was like sad we'd go there and like
spend it how we would spend like a
Saturday night watching the [ __ ]
Eagle you know or something you know
watching I wouldn't say that sad you're
a young guy yeah but you would look
around like this is oh when you look
around at the other people that are
there you get sad that's like why you
never eat in a McDonald's because you
look around and you see other people
that are sad or why you never make eye
contact with anybody when you're in a
Walmart Walmart Target those places are
great until you get to the checkout and
you look at other people and you're like
oh my god do I look like that and yes
you do look like that so it's a tough
look
um no but you just go like oh I should
be that's when it really hits you you're
like oh I should be home with my family
and loved ones but they're the guy in a
Carhartt jacket smoking cigs at the bar
call claiming claiming claiming stake on
the pool table next
yeah but there you said they were all
out your brother was with his girlfriend
and I don't know I mean it's midnight my
mom you know I mean people are home
again it's not like they it's not like
they went to Colorado for the month I
don't know I think that's okay and I'm a
big guilt guy you know that I love the
guilt I know but I'm telling you as the
guy who was there it's it's it's a
sobering moment if you're like I'd
rather spend the time
at the place I can spend the time at all
it's not like a special it's not like
they're having a Christmas party and
you're like I gotta get there it's you
know you're eating [ __ ] wings and
doing [ __ ] Jager Bombs or whatever
I'm sure you made it back there at some
point hit the fridge sure see we had
left in the envelopes for sure
oh man I tell you what that break
between Christmas Even if you were
working I had to work a couple of years
it wasn't that big deal yeah it was
still all right a month off just
chilling
I would have to yeah it was a lot it was
a lot of time
it was like always like December 15th to
January 17th or something Broncos there
was a couple of schools that had like
try semesters trimesters that was big
Delaware had that and I'd be like that
[ __ ] said I didn't have it today yeah
I think so they had something went there
they had something weird like that I
think it was Delaware Drexel did maybe
it was Drexel no I don't think Delaware
did I don't know maybe Drexel was
something real stupid right it was like
a trimester so they would go like they
never had like a full break they got
like a week off in the for Christmas and
then like three weeks off for the summer
I wouldn't remember I wouldn't have went
there yeah that would have been a deal
you didn't either so that's not saying
hey I would have never graduated from
that probably very true yeah I checked
that was the first thing I checked out
when's the winter break start what's the
deal sure and check out the cafeteria
and the birds see what's cooking on
campus oh established titles good Lord
ah yes Lord Jean Jack good lady you'll
soon be in a war with Lord dirty
underwear and I can tell you that gang
do yourself a favor favor get over to
established titles you can buy yourself
just one square foot of Scottish
woodlands and be called a lord or a lady
yes that's pretty sweet it's pretty
sweet we got plots uh me and a big man
got in there and T-Bones got one too
that's T-Bones right there so the first
200 people purchasing a title pack using
our link will effectively be next to our
plots within a few minutes of walking
baby we can build our own garbage King
tomorrow or our own Army we're coming
Charles we're coming for you baby Sir
William chicken tenders let's go guys it
makes a great last minute gift it's easy
peasy you go sign up officially change
your name to Lord lady you can use that
name on a credit card plane tickets use
it to land some ass like I would close
some deals you know what I'm saying uh
established titles is actually running
an early Black Friday sale plus if you
use the code garbage to get you get an
additional 10 off go to established
titles.com garbage get your gifts now
and help support the channel let's be
neighbors do it let's go
um all right this one's from ABE uh you
ever give a little kid relative a toy
without the batteries to use it
that's that's you're losing Uncle of the
year or Aunt of the Year Award right
there now you gotta come correct to make
sure they can use it immediately yeah
I'm a nerd with that stuff yeah I've
gone so far as I've put it together and
given it to them sure that makes sense
play with it a little bit before I give
it to you yeah but that kind of takes I
think they like the excitement of like
the box or whatever yeah giving them
like a completed thing is like kind of
[ __ ] whack
you know what I mean it wasn't a Lego
and it was one gift I remember
specifically it was when the Avengers
came out they had uh the quinjet and
they had a an Iron Man that flew
alongside of it then I got him a bunch
of other stuff too but that I opened and
put that together and that was like
played with it in the tub a little bit
too that was sitting on top of the big
pile of toys okay my mom used to do cool
stuff like that she'd set one or two
things up so it was all the presents
lined up in packages and then like one
or two things like you know like
showpiece sure yeah like a Macy's window
she did all right
yeah I don't know if we did that really
we also had to go back and uh
well we were when we were done opening
everything up and playing with all the
toys we had we had to like put
everything up we got to like organize
everything and put everything neat in
front of the Christmas tree so when
people came over
do a little face throwing yeah show him
the basketball net or whatever yeah yeah
that's real classy [ __ ] throwing it
in your loved one's faces how good your
Christmas was that's that's a kind of
[ __ ] dirt bag you are
show you show you show your less
fortunate cousins all your nice toys we
were the less fortunate cousin
play whatever it came in and kicked our
stuff
uh has their name on it there's from
last year
ah that was the worst getting jealous of
what other people got for Christmas
um
I remember this yeah I never I remember
this girl coming in she stated the
number of presents she had she's like I
got 27 presents
I remember where she lived and I'm like
this ain't were they from the dollar
store or something the batteries yeah
I'm like this don't make sense
you get a 12 pack of crayons this thing
like this ain't adding up
um if I got crayons I would have been a
problem
I think I probably got like an art set
of some remember those like classic Arts
that you would open up in like the
pastel colors were in there sure colored
pencils yeah I'm sure I'd ruin that in
about 15 minutes never lasted no ruin it
ruin it dog's eating the paintings yeah
there wasn't a toy that I didn't break
I remember one of my cousin's
girlfriends gave me and my brother
uh I got the Trans Am from smoking the
Bandit and he got the Dukes of Hazzard
car and it was like this but they were
bigger and like full of detail like it
was probably at the time 56 the hood
opened all that stuff I remember those
size cars dude you're like metal too
right yeah dude me and my brother we got
them she was watching he was babysitting
us they were in the room watching like a
movie or something like that me and my
brother went in the living room and just
started
smashing them together and literally
disintegrated them man she came in
bawling her eyes out yeah then my mom
came home and we [ __ ] got lit up and
I don't mean Christmas lights either
folks took a beating for that one hit
you with the old [ __ ] left left right
she comes out and buys you then you
destroy it you hit it with the Mickey
Ward body body body head
Dicky told me that and the big man came
downstairs started laying heat from the
top ropes with the elbow drop hey you
flashed a gun on us
how do you [ __ ] want to get sweet
started putting the car back together
like we worked at Pep Boys
um all right let's see here this is from
John have you or anyone you know never
had Bullet Hole stickers on your car no
that's trash that's trash I gotta say
you did not my stepdad did sure and we
thought it was the coolest thing yeah
when you're 10. it is cold
you know 42 whatever
uh no I mean I remember like really
thinking that was when those dropped
those magnets they were mag and I was
like this is the fight we are the
coolest family in the world you missed
the whole uh you were too young for the
windshield they had they would have
something on the windshield but they
dudes had banners on the windshield yeah
no they have like they had that when you
were a kid yeah I remember we were on
the lacrosse bus
one time and we were coming back from
the lacrosse game and this dude pulled
up in like a Geo Tracker some like 25
year old 20 year old [ __ ] [ __ ] it
yeah and on the windshield it said your
girls next dude we started where what's
the self-awareness level of like we
start talking that in your driveway dude
we started pelting that thing with
lacrosse balls and [ __ ] man that's
crazy we were hanging out the windows
screaming you loser then that's [ __ ]
crazy oh man that's wild you were girls
in that I told you that we saw one I I
think I said it that's the guy who's
definitely getting cheated on by the way
yeah I saw a guy that he had his said
just Ron Jeremy
which I was like that's odd to just like
dig up a [ __ ]
male porn star
like that's what you're driving around
that's like what you're that's your your
[ __ ] knock around car yeah it's crazy
yeah it's a bozo Wild
but the bullet holes are a little bit
different my stepdad was big into that
stuff of like he's like I'll put this on
Dave's Car Dave will think his car got
shot you know what I mean like it was
like there was like it was like weird
that exploding pen like just like weird
[ __ ] that you like I think you spent a
lot of time at Spencer's Gifts it felt
like you know what I mean now those
candles on the other hand I've seen a
couple of ants almost give themselves
emphysema trying to blow those things
out those were a good time the trick
handles but you knew the second that's
[ __ ] like the goddamn fourth of July
on those cakes you knew right away yeah
all right a couple of weeks I think in
around 86 87 that was a good time I
don't know
that yeah not my cup of tea no no huh
just hacking along all over the [ __ ]
cake I'm about to eat but we've learned
a lot since the pandemic sure okay
[ __ ] rocks uh this one's from Nick is
it garbage to decorate your front lawn
for Thanksgiving I.E an inflatable
turkey
I don't hate it
I'm big on that stuff but Thanksgiving
that's not a decoration holiday
hmm inside you got the centerpiece you
do like a [ __ ] whatever you know
you can do like stuff on the tables and
the the counter or whatever let me ask
you this that's shoot away because we
always would start with the Halloween
okay you start with the Halloween
decorations in the beginning of October
maybe a couple weeks before Halloween
sure then we would lightly transition
into the Thanksgiving decorations which
you take away to jack-o-lanterns you
take away the thing maybe leave a
pumpkin or a gourd or something like
that too but we always had the corn
stock on the stock was big huge always
had the corn stock on the mailbox sure
that's more that's more seasonal you're
okay with that yeah that's season you're
celebrating fall
at that point you know what I mean I
mean it was for the Bounty but that I
mean your problem is the the cartoonish
Thanksgiving plastic go rustic all day
go like a [ __ ] a gourd sure one of
those uh thing of squash the [ __ ]
hand turkey for the kids all day long
which I gotta say I don't like those
gourds man they look sick they're too
too phallic for me go to the
dermatologist
some Anbesol on that thing or something
take that away yikes give me a nice
pumpkin get a [ __ ] script of Valtrex
instead maybe a z-back who the hell are
these gourds hanging out at huh
razor burn I swear
[ __ ] monkey pox uh I'll give you that
yeah it's like I mean that's not like uh
no one ever drives around and looks at
the [ __ ] Thanksgiving Day decorations
nah you know what I mean yeah that's for
the parade you go to the [ __ ]
Thanksgiving Day Parade which is really
more Christmas
the Thanksgiving Day Parade
Santa Claus is the show stopper at that
yeah but that's the end of it yeah
yeah but I don't even know what was in
the Thanksgiving Day Parade it's all
cartoons and [ __ ] fire oh that's right
okay I'm thinking thinking small town it
was just a couple of fire trucks and the
Shriners one of those boys here's the
guys with the hats and the little cars I
always thought they were like
uh
uh who's married to one of the Kennedys
or who's again a Schreiber isn't that
Maria Shriver yeah I thought they were
Schwarzenegger's wife yeah I thought it
was like their family going or I didn't
know what I'm still not sure to be are
they the guys in the little cars with
the hats yeah dude the little zippers
that used to fly around those things are
bad I don't think I ever saw them in
person but anytime they were like this I
would hear it I don't know who was
booking the Wilkes-Barre Day
Thanksgiving Day Parade but they were on
point we had to Shrine dude they'd be
zipping around man when those guys hit
the streets look out I would hear
stories of like our parent my parents
would go out like the cousins would want
like my aunts and they'd all go out to
like some sort of event or fun rate or
something and you would I would hear
stories of Shriners were there so I
thought it was like a family at first
like the foleys the Jenkins they were
like the Shriners were there Toby can
you give me a Google I thought it was a
family for the longest time what are the
Shriners and the Elks I know what the
VFW is Alex is just like a social club I
know what the American Legion is I think
the Shriners are the same way but they
do a lot of charitable stuff I know
there's Shriners Hospital and what one's
marriages I don't know Shriner sounds
Shady bro Shriners International is a
fraternity based on fun fellowship and
the Masonic principles of Brotherly Love
relief and Truth slip that one in there
and the all-knowing gleap glory
to sign all your possessions over to
Zoltan
[ __ ] that dude
the second you start saying Masonic I'm
out later the Masonic principles of
Brotherly Love relief and truth that
sounds like they're choking each other
off and what are The Masons and sweet
sweet come
what are The Masons
because they're they do something I
thought they were the guys that were
hiding they're all Freemasons they're
also a fraternal organization that that
traced their Origins to the local Guilds
of stonemasons okay
yeah I don't know these guys aren't good
either quick layers I'll give you that
yeah back in the day but that's where
they would hide all the symbols we
shouldn't be talking about this
someone's gonna knock on the door real
quick
the Ben and black show up uh-huh I don't
like any of that stuff man any of the
Masons the [ __ ] secret societies no
we love it what are you talking about
it's the guy I mean I don't like it in
this sense it keep doing you just keep
me out here you know I don't want to
know anything
the Illuminati
no
we should start our own
cult we gotta have something you gotta
have like the cup of Christ or something
you got to have something cache but
people wanna people wanna mess with you
uh-huh we gotta get our hands on
something we got a pretty big Boba Fett
yeah how about some nudes at 30 or
something no all hail totally gotta get
like Hitler's UFO or something what you
gotta have something something weird
like that yeah
uh how do you guys feel about how
elaborate Halloween decorations have
been getting when you were talking about
the decorations I was thinking about the
little Halloween lights like the orange
Christmas lights great it's great I like
I'm okay with that because it is very
childish it's very like haunty haunted
house type stuff I'm I'm with all that
like this one look at what they did I
I'm with that Thanksgiving there's no
cachet to it you know what I mean
there's no like
Supernatural thing you have Santa you
have elves you have a flying reindeer at
Christmas Halloween you got Spears
witches goons God what's a goon to a
goblin the whole nine yard that's a deep
cut ah you're not gonna get that are you
old britches
um let's pull down my pants as you speak
uh but there's no like what do you sell
you know there's no like no there's
there's no cartoon aspect what's
thanksgiving's taking some heat lately
too I think everybody just shut up and
eat their turkey keep it zipped don't be
flaunting that stuff uh-huh doesn't have
the best history if you know sure you
see what I'm saying you know what I mean
it's zipped I do and there also isn't
anyone weirder on Earth than someone who
owns and operates a haunted house oh man
I worked with one a long time ago in
Michigan I don't know where the [ __ ] I
was
Hachi Machi he call Hannah that's what
he did during the day like I guess
off-season or whatever I don't know and
he was like hey man what are you doing
it was like during the day you're like
you can't be working on skeletons in
July dude I was bad it was bad I don't
know I could be into it I just watched
that uh Netflix movie with uh I think it
was Marlon Wayans who was in um why do
you say that weird Marlin
because there's multiple ways of
Worcestershire Waynes
um he's good uh who was in raccoon for a
dream is that Marlon Wayans yes yeah he
has a new movie with Kelly Rowland and
the little girl from uh stranger things
on Netflix about Halloween decorations
coming to life cute as a button it's
fantastic
good stuff that has nothing to do with
the actual reality of running a [ __ ]
bad haunted house you watched a movie
with famous people and you're like I I
could get behind that [ __ ] I like
haunted house the fake ones not like
I'll do like Eastern Penitentiary but
I'm not going to new Arena that's the
main haunted place where Eastern State
Penitentiary how many people died in
that place I know but they got kids and
stuff like that running around so it
keeps the energy or maybe they are I
really want to go in there solo I
wouldn't go anywhere near a haunted
house like a real haunted house
ever yeah no of course
um but I'm just saying the reality of
running like
I don't know it was uh it was a tough to
watch that was a tough reality to
uh to see in person that's all I'm
saying was to like go to like yard sales
looking for like props it was like a
spooky Carrot Top wait you worked for
the guy no if you listen to the program
I was working with the guy he was a
comic and in the office or whatever he
ran a haunted house okay in like Iowa or
something like you know on like a big
barn field
I think it was all year round or for
like you know like August to November or
December that's a good time though man
pumpkin picking the hay rides I didn't
mention any of that well if he's got
your romanticizing this why don't you
listen to what I'm saying
he's paying his addition to be spooky
and have the neighborhood comes in it
was a [ __ ] sad sight I don't know
what to tell you it sounds like tell me
more about your movie Sister sounds like
a setup yeah
okay uh yeah you can't decorate [ __ ]
that snow bueno
um no no bueno
love that Thanksgiving though tell you
that yeah it's probably my favorite one
of my because it's low expectations it
should be mandatory though that
everybody gets the Friday off
everybody should have Friday off every
Chef Wednesday off too let's take a week
okay figure it out you know what I mean
I don't mind the Wednesday because the
Wednesday you get done work you have
something to look forward to I know but
it kind of has that Christmas Eve energy
I know but you're you're looking at your
very specific situation if you have to
travel that day it [ __ ] sucks
I'll give you that so it's like all
right well hey we're gonna let you out
of three in New York and you got to get
to Philly
that nut it's like okay you're you're
fighting on the Subways you're fighting
on the [ __ ] trains and you're trying
to get an Uber you can't get an Uber
everything's all [ __ ] jacked up
Meanwhile your boys are all doing
[ __ ] key bumps at patties all right
here you go Wednesday so I'm told
Wednesday you're gonna be back at work
Tuesday that's what Thanksgiving I'd go
Monday shut it down Monday I'd go back
Monday we got Friday Saturday Sun Sunday
you're licking your wounds
that's what I'm saying
that's all I'm saying um I'm hankering
for some stuffing
yummy uh you know it was really cool to
see to get to give my wife her first
Thanksgiving of like she's only ever
heard about the how good the meal is and
I'm like oh it's gonna blow your [ __ ]
oh wow what'd you think yeah yeah she
loves it
it's great that's pretty cool yeah she's
like how good is it like it's better
than you could ever [ __ ] you could
ever put your [ __ ] little German
brain together yeah it's all right yeah
it's a good time it's all right but
you're saying I can put gravy on
everything
it's encouraged it's almost mandatory at
my place
um all right this one's from Chad do you
think it's acceptable to skip in front
of someone in line at a store so you can
purchase your items separately with
someone you know that's absolutely
unacceptable oh of course of course what
of course that's trash yeah if I was in
if we if you and I walked into a store
together uh-huh and I was in line and
you went to grab something and came back
here that's cool pay for this yo here by
the Yeah Yeah grab me that that doesn't
matter that doesn't no for sure that's
the that's the respectable gentleman
move I while standing behind that do get
a little upset that this guy's beat the
system I realize I'm it affects me in
zero percent except that this guy's not
suffering with me that's a couple thing
back but the guy suffered in line so
somebody that that okay
for me that is a unit right there if
they came into the store together
they're one person theoretically
but I'm sorry what I'm saying
the the the guy the head of you waited
in line yeah but I'm not are you talking
about a couple couple or two friends or
whatever yeah I view the two friends as
different really yeah
and I'm not saying I'm right I'm just
saying if me and you walked into a store
and then I went and stood in line the
whole time then you got to the line
you're like oh this is crazy long buy
this for me with intention to buy two
separate fit like you're gonna go buy
your
TV and I'm buying a bathing suit we're
not going to purchase that together
we're two individuals making two
separate I wouldn't do it with a TV what
do you mean no I'm saying you're in line
buying your TV then I'm like hey throw
these swim trunks on there that's not a
big deal I don't think I'm okay with
that I don't know because I feel like
they're two separate purchases nah I'm
cool with that now if you were like of
course if you do are you joining me in
the line or are you saying here pay for
this I'll meet you out front
I think I think the question is joining
you in line that's yeah that's what I'm
saying no the set the question is
separate purchase which is egregious
yeah I'm going even one step further
saying I as a crazy person behind that I
still go like [ __ ] this guy beat me
because he didn't have to wait in line
do you see what I'm saying I'm not
saying I'm right sure I'm just saying
that's how I feel sure of going [ __ ]
this guy won because I've had to wait
for and obviously you gotta
to paint the thing this is a long line
otherwise you would just wait right you
know what I mean so like you're to wait
in line you've been taxed I've been
waiting here for 10 minutes and this guy
just comes in I get this and you're like
[ __ ] you you just won that bothers me
the way I see it if one person is paying
somebody can bring something up hey I
forgot this here you go
yeah no I agree with you I I get that
you're a psycho and you freak out I
would be I would be too but I was
looking if you were standing in line
okay and I was in front of you
and Toby walked up and said I forgot
this and Toby got in line behind me I
paid for my stuff and left Toby pay for
his stuff in his lap that's gonna be a
[ __ ] problem oh yeah I would say
something that's what this guy's talking
about I know yeah yeah crazy that's
unacceptable he says he feels like he's
like I feel like I probably wouldn't say
anything because I'm a [ __ ] but there'd
probably be something that's so
egregious I would I would I wouldn't be
like hey well you know I'd be like well
I would be like that's crazy like I
would like at least 70 year old Vietnam
vet with a [ __ ] any [ __ ] jackpot I
don't [ __ ] with those dudes wearing
those hats that I don't understand those
dudes with all this stuff nobody thank
you for yours no Korean war vet Vietnam
war with those guys will knock you the
[ __ ] out
now that [ __ ] but like
yeah no I agree that
that is the right thing but in my psycho
brand and go [ __ ] you've
you should have to suffer like the rest
of us what if it's a couple what if a
couple's waiting in line in front of you
and that's a unit yeah I'm saying he's
like you forgot the milk ah [ __ ] I
forgot the milk and she ran back of
course that's a unit I'm saying two
people who go in to make separate
purchases I'm saying I would get mad if
that guy was going to make a separate
purchase but since the line so long goes
buy that let me ask you this I go that's
[ __ ] up because I have to sit here and
suffer like a jamoke let me ask you this
what what kind of bathing suit were you
getting two-piece g string which I'm
back by the way oh that wasn't even
going away they went away they're
stronger than ever
the thong the G string I was walking on
the pool with their butt hanging out
first song I ever downloaded illegally
The Thong Song shout out to Cisco
sucker
come get me if you want me federal
government
I owe Hollywood about 10 million dollars
I don't really steal a hole I don't
pirate a whole bunch not anymore
you got the subscription even then we
didn't have a computer that could really
handle it I'd have to do it at my
buddy's house who had Kate like who if
you didn't have cable modem at the time
to download an album took months I took
Columbia house for a ride that was it
yeah whatever I mean they were expecting
that yeah shout out to Hollywood Video
I'd rent the DVDs and then pop them in
my DVD burner yeah guys had a DVD
burners that's crazy I remember so
that's some kid Andrew had when I was
like you might as well have been the CIA
if you had one of those
holy [ __ ] that's real I didn't even
understand setting up two VCRs to like
people were doing that with like CKY and
stuff and I'm going I don't know what
the [ __ ] I don't know how my dad figured
it out he told you he taped that stuff
off HBO well that's that was a button
that was just like a record on that
which we still didn't we've never my
family has never recorded anything off
TV ever but I can wrap my head around
there was a record and play button on
the VCR ours didn't I thought just the
VCR rewinders were wild man you're over
there ripping and burning I thought he
had one that was a Was a Race Car sure
they did I remember being like what what
do you work for Blockbuster where did
you get your hands on this New Age
Technology this one is uh from Steven is
it garbage to go to the exit of a
grocery store go through the exit of a
grocery store when you first walk in so
you don't have to walk all the way
around to the entrance and get what you
need [ __ ] all that [ __ ] no not at all
that's [ __ ] get out of here with
that exit and exit now you're I don't
understand what you're saying you walk
yes you walk right through yeah I
remember finding out you could do that
with just a little pressure
it was when I was working at a grocery
store that was you could like really
[ __ ]
uh because I think the one I used to go
was two separate ones in and out so they
wouldn't open you know what I mean it
was like the it was the proper like
swing Open Door not to slide so you had
to go through each one uh but then they
like redid it or something and I
remember being like what the [ __ ] this
is but I felt like the coolest I feel
like a bouncer like I don't have to
listen to rules excuse me yeah Bebop and
scat like you know the like you know the
passcode to get in when I was a kid
though walking through the checkout the
other way you felt like you were going
in to do a bank job if you would walk
you go through like an empty one yeah
you're saying to like cut through yeah
yeah I work here excuse me like you feel
a real [ __ ] top breath the other
bozos walk around me I scoot through
aisle four I do like to walk into the
main entrance of the grocery store to
get the full experience especially in
The Burbs they're real nice got the
flowers over here the produce over here
they're cooking something in the bakery
you see the deli guy and the guys going
yeah
find some chicken somewhere it's all
right yeah it's not too sure toes
rolling around
love me a roto but we gotta wrap it up
gang what a fun time we love yous
appreciate all the goddamn support we'll
see you out there on the road somewhere
pick up some tickies
pick up some cards do yourself a favor
because they're going hot baby grab the
cards for the supplies while the
supplies last there we are running low
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace